citizens of the reject Nation do you
remember how last week we said hey look
at us we're on a path it's finally going
to make sense going on a linear Journey
well guess what
Batman versus Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles is not on that linear journey
and yet here we are yes 2014 is 2019 we
skipped ahead like five years we're
gonna go back at some point if you share
this video grab he's like hey you guys
should watch Batman versus teen Mutant
Ninja Turtles like all right didn't know
what I was getting into today it's just
one step closer to us reading Batman
versus Predator together on screen if
you want that also leave a comment below
I'm great I'm really excited for this
even though it's Divergence I feel like
this is going to be so much fun because
I grew up with turtles so yeah same
Kevin Eastman Boston boy those Turtles
were invented in a Boston pizza shop
hey no wonder they love pizzas so even
though Daredevils in New York which is
how the turtles Exist by the way if you
didn't know the Ooze is the very thing
that blinded Daredevil that is Canon
they can't say it legally but you can
ask Kevin Eastman he'll tell you that is
literally the same ooze that made
Splinter and the turtles but blinded
Matt Murdock and that same spill so that
might have happened in New York but it
happened here in Boston and without
further Ado let's go to the buff the
Boston of DC Comics Gotham with Batman
vs Superman versus Ninja Turtles
please do like and subscribe hit that
notification Bell do leave some comments
do you want to see us reading Batman vs
Predator do you want us to watch I don't
know the Avengers animation what do you
want you let us know in the comments and
if you want to watch the synced up Line
to Line start to finish without pause
except to see our pause faces
become a patron and get very sexy and
very good content of us enjoying the
journey but without further Ado because
I've been talking for the length of some
Ninja Turtles films it's time for Batman
versus Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
that's natural predator the turtle
ah see Nickelodeon that is probably why
it's not an HBO knitting and not on your
streaming service that's the subtext
yeah what would they call it slime snake
bring it back bring back snake oh
that was cool classic oh this looks like
the Animated Series this is gorgeous
our Deco flavor ninjas
cool if the generator is as powerful and
runs as clean as reported it'll change
the
what is it Babs
[Music]
or the hand
right away my dude I was always
Donatello growing up oh yeah yeah I see
that they took the generator into the
wrong hands it could blow up a city
block
we have to stop them Batman
they're going to regret stepping foot
and Gotham
cool somehow this is yeah like so cool
and so like epic dark and epic but also
it's like the wackiest yeah that's a
crazy Duo and it's blending Both Worlds
so well now it's the spirit yeah their
fighting style is consistent with
ancient forms of ninjutsu the League of
Assassins perhaps
great there are meta-humans involved as
well monstrous creatures certainly
Gotham needs more of those some kind of
Suicide Squad
[Music]
Montage suit up
yes
I'm watching Turtles the genius that I
am I figure we hit the Wayne Lab First
and sell the tech to our new friend
whoever no Batman tattoo
that's awesome she's literally branded
no Batman they steal these umbrellas
from a hot dog on a stick definitely
Wayne Enterprises Cloud feeder testing
commencing
ah yeah the boss gave him the night off
me I always work late
nice shot
[Music]
no
who's ready to talk
[Music]
where is she where is he show yourself
oh it's the bat fire fire
nah he's wearing his red mask today it's
rough man look at his name right what
they are killer
oh they're not aliens though we're
Turtles no not the time Donny good
clarification the time for accuracy Leah
absolutely my guy that's a recent
reference to uh take a job at I respect
it
yeah all right
oh jeez
e
he's got a gun umbrella
a gun brother
my Leo
where's Shredder Shredder what's a
shredder you face the penguin
[Music]
all right
it's a sword relative I think I love
this little guy he should adopt him go
live in the sewer together it's true it
fit in please leave me no choice
there it is
a little Back to the Future
whoa oh nice
now what does a ninja Clan want with an
experimental Cloud Cedar where are your
meta-humans you mean the turtles turtles
that one kills oh
Shredder you just say his own name no I
said it oh that's a weird move it's my
audition tape for the next installments
dang Batman
oh that's a question I never know I
needed to have answered
and if your name is Shredder you gotta
have the top of the line that's late
better shred
I love the ringing too with these pipes
yeah the sound Design's been solid yeah
oh nice shot man like the choreography
in the camera always they really care
how Batman fights crunching
oh I love the animation man
oh
wow
whoa
oh no
we had to chase Shredder from New York
all the way to Gotham City we should at
least enjoy it right I don't know Gotham
and New York are pretty much the same
let's just say how far of a trip is that
does New York have mad flims flying
around for no reason
[Music]
I mean like what are they for I love
them yes
what is it it had better be
good
oh
yeah
[Music]
I am the Knight so cool the penguin
mentioned a bat think this is the guy
working with shredder could be wait for
my signal too no I got this no dude
[Music]
this is music cute yeah the music's cool
[Applause]
oh there's a crazy guy in a bat suit
who's trying to kill us
toad that's battle toads a Sega Genesis
franchise
[Music]
it's always such soggy but such
delicious looking pizza it always looks
like the yeah the cheesiest the
cheesiest yeah the gooiest it's gonna
take more than a jerk in a Halloween
costume to shock me taser level seven
oh no I love that that was a bit of a of
a bat pun you know shock me uh yep yep
it's ninja vanish time ninja
Turtles
yep oh it's good you got a lot to learn
bats oh man from behind the cowl the
Ninja Turtle reveal I trust you procured
the cloud Cedar from Wayne Enterprises
obviously without it I can't finish the
machine
we do not yet have the device
[Music]
further I like how they cast a gold
blooming type for the fly
it's got some fly energy yes
you will have to explain this setback to
our partner I will deal with him when he
arrives deal with me
oh damn
laugh I got my ninjas too
it seems things have gone poorly while
I've been on Route Ken Watanabe play
shredder too are these both Ken Watson
Hobbies oh my God no
I gotta check that I checked that and
while Ken Watanabe has not played
Shredder yet a lot of people online are
very enthusiastic about it so start that
petition all you had to do was build a
machine the machine is nearly complete
Baxter Stockman I'm building it
hahaha
if it's a demonstration you want
who's it up Secret of the Ooze
don't worry he'll live of course
oh nice
Gotham's own citizens will tear their
City to the ground follow
[Applause]
oh which one my man yeah yeah we'll take
a bets I I think I'm gonna go Tim Drake
who you got I'm gonna go Jason Todd okay
just for fun he wanted to figure us out
okay Bros I broke it down a little about
throwing things cool car sweet Bad Hat
awesome kicked our butts maybe evil mean
voice
you're pleased with himself big boys I
made a database of every reported Batman
sighting and ran it through an algorithm
that triangulated against the city's
police records and natural cave
formations huh where are you taking us
the answer should be right through
oh
nice that easy
the batsonian collection the original
Batman costume like the first issue the
red one yeah yeah Batman cave Batman
cave this is amazing I don't know what
to put my grubby paws on first Nike all
of it hey guys check it out I'm Batman
yes
how did you get in here hey
ouch we didn't come here to fight oh
listen shrimp you don't want to do this
oh yes I
I get off on this kind of thing it's
kind of kind of my whole thing
before Dad gets home how did you get
into this cave there weren't many
security measures in the northern tunnel
you had to swim for a bit but I'm
realizing you don't actually want
constructive criticism
how crazy the show we came to Gotham to
stop Shredder and the Foot Clan honestly
we thought you might be Shredder's new
partner Shredder so that's his name why
did you say that I thought they'd went
extinct ages ago coming together you
know
so are we not gonna beat up losers then
I may as well tell you that I know
exactly whose Shredder and the foot are
working with oh as if Damien then is it
Damian he seems nice for that I can't
tell he seemed to want to throw down
[Music]
oh
that was a dope shot yeah man
I love how a horror movie this sequence
is yeah
oh
[Music]
thanks Mary
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes the man who'll help us Destroy This
City
is right behind the door
you're going for the biggest bat of all
it's gonna be like three little Diamond
Tweedle D it's not Joker it's fat might
that might young lady I assure you
there's no amount of greasy cheese bread
that could surpass my abilities
I want pizza is so bad right I want like
this is dangerous I can't watch any
Ninja Turtle thing without killing me
starvation oh no oh boy
oh no
oh Pizza
wow yeah Ross obviously has plans for
the mutagen your Shredder brought into
the city who's we call it ooze
they build some kind of gizmo and in
return Shredder gets a pit the Lazarus
Pit a mosh pit It's Magic grants
immortality to any who bathe in it an
immortal Shredder
that would
suck yeah right now there's a 40 chance
of lethal side effects
I agree with the turtle go stand over
there
definitely Damien yep
the great bad family though yeah it's
solid never seen an attack like that it
must have been the satooshi strike ooh
powerful ninja technique that dates back
hundreds of years it focuses all the
body's energy into a single blow only
two living ninja Masters know how to
utilize its full power my father's
splinter
and the shredder cool yeah man I love
the art stuff yeah I love mixing it up
into the classic yeah
killing me Turtles
who has better Pizza New York or Gotham
oh I'm gonna go to New York but water
quality minimum
all the mutations in Gotham everybody
looks like two-faced after some Gothic
beats
Leonardo and his brothers are important
assets you'll have to follow orders this
is still my city deal we're definitely
gonna want a red pizza
pizza utility belt I trust you have what
I want
[Music]
oh yeah family recipe passed down to me
by my dear Mommy Joker who has been
killed by the way
this man is an idiot
I've got what you wanted now pay up
Shredder
pay the clown
oh no Teenage Mutant Ninja Joker yes yes
sorry barbarino no middle-aged Mutant
Ninja joke
depressed washed up comedians
Todd Phillips's third film it's Arkham
alarms went off an hour ago but when
we've got the perimeter locked down but
we have to assume there are hostages
inside
all of them
seven ninjas
that never gets old I'm still here
whoa yep it was a skateboard give us a
pizza oh Mikey archimed its inmates are
too dangerous to take any chances
hit
[Music]
oh he's on the skateboard that was a
good kickflip SolidWorks attention
inmates of Arkham
Joker here oh boy let's go I've got a
brand new medication regimen for you oh
the Joker toxin mixed with turtles
[Music]
oh man
wow
oh my
whoa
[Music]
whoa nice
[Laughter]
cool love that choice
you find Mr Jay and who's got a whole
thing planned I don't want to ruin it
you know
[Applause]
eyes are so creepy terrified was this
their plan mutate the villains and
unleash them on the city there are
hostages to rescue these inmates were
the deadliest criminals in all of Gotham
no pressure we got this good pep talk
Dad no creepy animals in here
says the creepy Manimal I'm a super
chill Manimal
oh Mr Freeze
polar bear with a gun's pretty intense
look here with an ice gun that is so
cool
[Music]
respect thinking Joker's gonna be a
jackal Bane some sort of like he's like
a chupacabra yeah oh no not that I've
encountered it might change your
mannerisms but you're still you I
disagree
about to find out
Dane I feel like a new man oh okay
we get hurt so bad again with a punching
bag oh
this would be a cool video game it
really would especially after that
Batman exposition
oh
hey hello Batman cool not as afraid as
you're going to be
big old crow scarecrow Dr Jonathan crane
calls himself scarecrow really
I mean you always need that more time
you spend at Gotham here's a fear guest
that can make you see things that aren't
real
oh
let's go what do turtles see
wow
oh wow
everyone is gone
not bad that's a polar bear yep
[Music]
[Applause]
hey creature leave that kid alone
nicely done it's great Mikey
[Music]
wait for a second there there's merch
Mikey's Jesus
yeah I work as a team
well hang on what are those bad idea bad
idea
that idea you gotta trust Damian
[Applause]
yes nicely done
foreign
[Applause]
wow the antidote to cranes gas let's
move
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes I never realized what my true
potential was
Venus flytrap's clever huh worse it's a
carnivorous plant
[Music]
feed me for real
she Carriage
wait here please walk around her
no
oh
Siamese cats Joker
cool
wait for my signal nuts to that it's
rescue in time
Ninja Run they do it too Joker always
has a trap
oh listen to Batman
oh no oh right bad guy rematch rematch
yes
oh this city it's villains oh we were in
such a rut oh this is ooh is really
shaking things up I don't know if it was
gonna be robbing or Batman that got
turned yeah when you combine the blues
with my little tincture you get
something new something that not only
transforms you it drives you mad
why I only have enough for one
oh
wow wow
[Music]
a Batman
or a bad Batman be a man bat or a
Man-Bat who laughs
oh the gray and blue is so cool to do
that with
[Music]
Batman father Daddy I don't think Batman
is home right now
looks like one of the Gargoyles yeah
Batgirl the anti-oos retromutagen and
it's right here
hold still
oh guys oh
[Music]
come on
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
guess what Val Kilmer saw in the cave
yeah
I'm gonna be okay
you saved him thank you
Brothers
foreign
love your boots
[Music]
but if Shredder and the foot aren't even
here then this whole damn thing was just
a giant distraction oh man that's of
course the plot thickens of course
they're going to bloodhaven my newfound
associate left me little Choice a
genuine One of a Kind Wayne Enterprises
Cloud Cedar man
what about my finders fee quite a lot of
money was discussed reminds me of Lionel
Barrymore
there is no money
I can kill him
oh yeah ooze with Joker's formula and
launched a jokerized ooze into the
clouds above the city it'll turn
everyone income into a monster mutant
like Batman did everyone else know that
Batman is Bruce Wayne
[Laughter]
[Music]
if they're dug in and ready for a fight
then we bring them a freaking fight we
aren't doing anything oh how's the Bruce
you are not well
I'm as well as I need to be oh you four
are impulsive and you don't follow
orders I want you out of Gotham
ouch when things get tough
I don't even bother with them I go off
on my own I do things my way he does do
that
sure we make mistakes sure we make the
wrong moves but we can't get better if
you don't trust us
touch Batman
[Music]
that backhand learning from your
mistakes together is how a family Works
asking a family oh it's a team
ain't that the same thing oh hey let's
stop Roz and Shredder together
awesome yeah
we have our own ride don't care call
Batmobile
is it is it is it let's do this let's
see it let's see the side by side give
me the Fast and Furious give me the
Batmobile van give me
just don't press
[Laughter]
so excited for him yeah
he's right around in this thing on
purpose
yeah it's so many great features that
spoiler and the mask
yes it is I also like that clearly race
and Shredder have seen uh The Amazing
Spider-Man oh yeah very much so very
reminiscent plan need it needed that
nice
Johnny
let's do this
Bossa Nova
nice
whoa
dang that girl you're up
cool I wonder who makes all of her
accessories Alfred Alfred is a crafty
guy
yeah nice
[Music]
oh
throw actual pizzas they gotta be hungry
[Music]
ah cool mutagen
pigeon got three yeah I was gonna say
conserve some of those pretty hardcore
oh Elephant Man
he might need three hey trunks don't
forget to duck
[Music]
oh boy oh good timing
I told him to duck
is that a giant possum playing dead oh
it's a dinosaur oh
they are there press some buttons
[Laughter]
Michelangelo press some buttons
oh that's okay buddy you'll get your
time one of these days oh man this is
good
nice job yes yes that smile that smile
never leave the cave without it
nice
dang that
random foot just got to be a T-Rex you
never know what your genetics hide I
guess win the lottery there
time for this city to revert to its
Primal nature and destroy itself yes sir
seem to take a shot of that villainy now
that he knows he's a hostage he's like
I'll be a bad guy yeah now nothing can
stand in my way oh
[Music]
monk
what a splash page let's take him down
oh boy
crate shot oh
cool so rad
shut off the cloud Cedar I think you
forgot how our last encounter played out
oh boy
oh takes four of them to take out
Shredder Let's see we got bats Batman
sends children to do his work for him
perhaps another Must Die to teach him
the Folly of his ways
they didn't make it
[Music]
wow one-handed you you huh prepare to
defend yourself with whatever formidable
abilities you may present and I'm
basically a hostage don't hit me
oh golly
giving off like Submariner Vibes in his
pants like this yeah
but can he fly
hardcore ah dang one hand behind his
back
oh no
don't let the fear get into your head I
was afraid he's gonna fall into the ace
chemicals me Joker turtle
would suck but they would also be kind
of cool so much has happened already
oh
oh no Donnie this is exactly the
opposite of your job you don't want to
be there
oh
what about it's designed like a drone
[Music]
oh no
your anger won't help your brothers you
have to focus
oh nice
[Music]
oh wow
come on Leonard how
I'm hundreds of years old how could you
possibly
well I'm 16. and I learned this from a
rat
ah
it's beautiful
a nut punch and then the five-point Palm
exploding heart technique everything you
need
Cowabunga yes
Batman just said cowabunga
bat punch
oh nice
yeah get him on the ropes
got a rope-a-dope Shredder come on the
defense
depressing blindly is yeah
you do machines I'm the party dude
oh God Mikey whatever you did keep doing
it
push every Button he's the party dude if
you overheat the generator
[Applause]
you guys are you guys are on that
you want to make sure that orb doesn't
just land and Gotham yeah
smart cool
[Music]
I knew there had to be a reason for all
these blimps
yes that's awesome
oh wow dude
looking Frank millerish too Nickelodeon
for adults yeah the fourth and the
league are mine
[Music]
speaking of
oh oh boy
Joker Shredder oh that's not good
shredker
and that's the end of ace chemicals it
never comes back no way Shredder could
have survived that I still can't believe
master Bruce actually said Cowabunga
yep your father will be very proud thank
you let's keep in touch sure my handle
online is Oracle
oh I see you
both staffs are cool
good with both stuff
it was an honor to fight with you and
your more frivolous Brothers you are
also weird you are also weird
I'm very sorry about before so to make
it up to you please accept my skateboard
[Laughter]
just what I've always wanted
yes it is
all right guys let's go home love their
license plates Turtle Wax too oh that's
good leave now oh pizza party
Pizza time yes
Alfred with the fork and knife
come on come on Damien
live a little
it's all the kid needed was a little
pizza now he's gonna be friendly and
nice chill as heck now
minutes yeah he's a folder yeah what's
wrong with that butter style that was so
good God that wasn't that was so good
blast
and the Joker what attack what that is
incredible wow Kyle Moon he was
Michelangelo oh Darren Chris is Raphael
okay dude can you imagine being Batman
and the Joker that's that's such a oh
Rachel Bloom is Batgirl man oh that's
cool yeah that's such a responsibility
I'm kidding
I thought that was Terror strong yeah do
the original comic covers to the Neil
Adams this is awesome they like remade
them to adding turtle and bat elements
to Classic covers yeah
that's so cool Batman Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles the Frank Miller cover the
Neil Adams [__] that might be my
favorite up there oh this crossover
added the turtles to it
oh these are so great it's so clever
they can actually get the style like
really well done to add the other side
of the element to it yeah
that's great
so they were consciously making that
like a Neil Adams style I see when they
cast Pattinson I thought this was the
body type they were gonna go for and
they were gonna do the blue and the gray
then because he looks more aesthetically
like Neil Adams which is this body type
but now that they're going with the bat
family I think they're gonna do the Blue
and Gray and go that way the yeah the
original Batman but it's instead of
Robin jumping through its Turtle oh
that's awesome oh Batman year One but
sure Batman sure
oh that's the Psychiatry issue the the
like that was like mid 60s when uh 66
was getting really popular
Batman went to therapy I mean for the
children just on the cover
I assume some of these are uh one before
my time but also I think some of them
are turtle covered like this one here
now okay gotcha but yeah that's that's
the original uh run
um and that was like oh there's nothing
there's that ridiculous Nightwing
costume oh the most iconic of Neil Adam
art that's beautiful
Batman and Michelangelo so great
perf
uh the fight's sorrow yeah love it
it's Jim Starlin uh before he killed the
bat uh before he killed Robin
oh there's the original cover so they
added Batman to the left but that so
that covers the the very first uh
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles oh awesome
that was cool man that was an absolute
Delight like so much love
shredker
yep yep
oh
the shredder who laughs
oh yeah God he's gotta have that Spike
yeah yeah he's literally like
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes oh so cool
dude dude
my favorite
really like it's up there with Arkham in
terms of just like sheer just Joy
gleeful Joy like red hood and stuff
maybe like you know more artsy like more
intellectuals this is just a lot more
dramatic but yeah yeah this like from
the get this felt like everyone involved
was like given this opportunity of like
if we just had one chance to make a
Batman and Ninja Turtles movie you only
get one shot you have every Teenage
Dream you've ever wanted and one moment
crossover would you capture it or let it
slip exactly and and Palms were sweaty
as they walked in but they put like
everything in here as it felt like they
played every possible thing you would
want to see every little joke nice
little meta things about each property
responding to each other like it's a
really great action comedy dense with
reference and like it didn't feel
heavy-handed like there was so much
going on there yeah and like it fit like
the worlds the styles of Animation the
humor I love that like they very they
did the comic thing well where they
paired everyone off and they made it
like feel like synchronistically they
had a big Arkham Escape like so much of
this worked sure well and that's the
thing too is it it it had that quality
where they actually had me distracted
because they're in Arkham you're dealing
with the Rogues Gallery being all
mutated and then when that's done I'm
like okay cool oh wait that's right they
actually yeah they actually they do this
I forgot all about the the yeah the
weather seater or whatever it was called
which is the it rarely does the goal of
the villain actually go like I wasn't
distracted like I was actually in the
second act yeah to the point I totally
agree and like the the joy of it like
there was so maybe that's why this is my
number one because you can tell the Red
Hood story in comics obviously because
they did as you can tell uh the Arkham
in video games but like this felt unique
to animation and joy like this felt like
what I think of with like childhood
cartoons and adulthood cartoons mixed
together sure and like I can have joy
reading a comic obviously it's my
favorite medium but there's something to
that freedom and the sense of wonder
that comes from cartoons cartoons versus
animation which I do think there is a
distinction this did what the strength
of animation and the strength of
cartoons sure like this is just
happiness no it really was because they
make like a perfect unlikely crossover
in that you have all the ingredients
through the turtles for comedy and the
bat family in various ways provides
their own specific humor but more so
opportunities to be the straight man and
so you have something that yeah like
when it wants to be dramatic in like
again not to not in like an overly
pretentious way but yeah in the more
serious moments it reads and in the fun
moments it reads and nothing ever feels
like it's being undercut or sacrificed
for like oh I'm gonna put a joke here
like some Marvel movies when there's too
many jokes it like loses like uh Age of
Ultron I always think of like after
Ultron kill someone there's like a joke
as he flies off in the sky and I was
like like James Spader's great but I'll
always think of that as like ah and this
didn't do that at any point it just
stayed a certain flavor yeah and it
wasn't all light there were Darkness
moments yeah oh man this and like I also
like we talked a lot about Daredevil
obviously paralleling the turtles
because that is the origin but I never
put together how much Batman and his
family is like splinter in his family
sure like there's there's elements there
where those things tie together in a
really interesting way and I never
thought of like some of the bat family
lining up so directly with the turtles
like there's a lot of really fun comicky
parallels yeah and I was I was that's no
I'm not like upset it didn't happen
because they do you know mention like oh
you know our dad's gonna be mad that
we're out but like it would have been
cool to see some kind of like Splinter
shows up and it's like hey thanks for
looking after them yeah yeah
uh but in the night when we're hanging
out yeah this is the thing in my head
Cannon like and I don't know if there's
a sequel to this but like if they're
ready to see it realized like with Joker
shredder like that's that's the perfect
sting for fun even if you're never going
to realize it but at the same time if it
were to happen I would be like sign me
up please Joker Shredder goes to New
York and Batman has to come stop crying
oh and so they said it in their
territory that one that would be yeah
the other way so you got Batman as a
fish out of water in a New York Turtle
setting and I love the way that they use
like yeah their knowledge of the sewers
and their innate abilities to like you
know they find the bat cave and then you
know it seems to make some level of
sense that Rachel ghoul and Shredder
would be somehow working together and
they have these rival Mystic ninja clans
and stuff like that like they they
really rode the right line of like using
some of the innate Whimsy and silliness
but yeah so giving you like pretty
decent reasons as to why certain
characters would be involved the way
they are I love the way they use penguin
throughout this and because Turtles can
be dark and Batman can be light yeah and
then showed that yeah and and light
without it being like Batman just be
here cracking joke like even the
cowabunga thing they have a reasonable
experience right that was a perfect
example yeah that's a perfect like I
love that they then gave it a beat of
like rationale even though I wouldn't
have minded it it might have been like
that was weird but like then they even
validated that yeah and then they have a
pizza party and it's like it's all you
ever wanted man there were so many lines
of dialogue I never knew I needed I know
like this is one I would definitely want
to like put back on again because I'm
sure that In the Heat of the Moment the
first time watching tons of little great
visual gags and references I'm sure a
little thrown out their lines and things
like that and and like great voice cast
all around yeah totally agree yeah I now
want to see that Scooby-Doo Batman right
there yeah right like now that I know
this exists I'm so if you told me that
Scooby-Doo Batman I knew it existed but
if you told me it would be like a must
watch I this was the Gateway now like I
want to see all the Batman and yeah
because this is so much fun yeah
absolutely I was thinking about that
Predator 7.1 on IMDb what cowards think
this is the C because it's got a great
four and a half on whatever Amazon but
IMDb what's stuck up angry bat fans what
what Batman should only murder the good
name of my Batman comics by bringing
this riff raff in here not enough pearls
in here with the turtles was it oh they
could have retconned Batman's origin to
where Shredder was the one who killed
his parents that would be great and then
that would be the way too serious
managed Turtles movie you see the Ooze
is actually the Joker uh ace chemicals
and ace chemicals is what caused the the
turtles in the first place there you go
it's them coming back for revenge in the
dark gritty Noir you totally they're
angry now
it's just a bunch of like Moody teens
like they are all Raphael now
oh that was so much fun yeah I also
think you could like play around with
like which Robin gets along with which
one they could come back to Gotham and
like Nightwing gets along with Leonardo
because he's the one that like became
the leader by default like they both got
the Loop yeah like there's so many great
little coincidental parallels and things
like that and yeah everybody serves
their purpose while maintaining like the
the distinct charm of each of their
characters and with so many characters
of balance like seven team members like
three bat family and then four and no
one felt like they were shortchanged no
yeah and it's like you got two stories
that felt like they'd married together
like I loved the beginning where you're
in the Batman World it feels like the
Animated Series then you see the turtles
from various people's perspectives you
don't know exactly what to think about
them even though we all know and then
they kind of show you Batman from their
perspective after that yeah you get both
per you kind of get the fusion of here's
the version of the movie where we're
following Batman here's the version of
the movie we're following the turtles
and then they smurge together and it's
it's a beautiful synthesis it's like a
five-ishu miniseries where like One
issues Batman One issues Turtles One
issues Batman like it goes back and
forth with artists and writers yeah so
it feels like both and then the last
one's like Batman and the turtles Alpha
like where they have like a one issue
that like yeah I don't agree they did
that so well that's not easy no not at
all and like the the fight choreography
yeah like they put so much time and I've
seen on a few of these animated movies
we've watched people commenting like man
these fights feel live action yeah like
the way they choreograph both the
fighting but also the camera movements
and stuff is is gorgeous that one's
still frame where they had the action
happen in the frame with all the fights
like the other like side scroller
moments and it was like yeah that was so
good yeah like so many great like iconic
little shots that either evoke a comic
book or evoke a movie that you would
need like the motion to create and uh
and yeah like super gratifying
team-ups villain and corporations like
all that stuff and also some classic
images too like like the way they did uh
shredders like Master move yeah like
made a lot of sense wasn't too
convoluted and they did the whole like
Japanese art style for that and then
yeah that classic like loving the blue
and gray suit but also that classic like
Batman poser to me it's classic where
there's that one shot on the stairwell
where all the Foot Clan or getting ready
to whip their swords out of Batman's
just looking up at them and he's got the
cape covering it's draped out on the
floor it's almost like his arms are just
kind of down to the sides and you're
sort of looking down and he's Spotlight
and they're just like wow like what a
great classic iconic you know Spirit of
Batman image and then you know the
animation of the turtles too like I've
seen the Turtles pop up in so many
different iterations over time and you
know people have their various feelings
about how they look each time but I
really like how they animated them here
um and the way that they each had a
different slight you know the
differences in each of their designs and
the way they
they're like uh they're like Marauder
masks yeah whatever those are someone in
the chat's like it's the thing and I'm
sorry uh like the way they function is
almost like ears basically yeah
effectively yeah I yeah this is there's
like tears for me there's the this red
hood and Arkham and then there's like
you know the the last one we watched
Batman versus Robin and and like the the
like this is like an A and that's like a
a minus and then there's like the ones
that are good and enjoyable like bees
this was such an a like this was four
and a half Stars 7.1 IMDb I'm just mad
at it
just anger scales I've seldom the scene
one where I'm not like what really bad
this is odd and and and and matches
nowhere on any other one
yeah disagree well this was an absolute
blast I enjoyed it so very much uh I
hope there's a sequel I hope there's
also uh I hope Batman is really by the
same people when he teams up Scooby-Doo
I now also hope with James Gunn you know
having directed Scooby-Doo and taking
over the DC Universe we get a live
action you bring back Matt Lillard and
you have him here for that you have him
team up with whoever the new Batman is
you make that happen I'm here for that
and and we get the Alfred uh you know
six uh skateboards 100 yeah demo his
skateboard so actually screw and uh if
there is a sequel to this good but if
there's not live action if there's a
sequel I want the third James Gunn you
direct me Scooby-Doo three teams up
Batman in the DCU and I am in man I love
this all right that is gonna do it for
this week who knows what's next week
only Greg and he'll only know next week
we'll find out in real time yeah yeah
yeah he's the who's the mad scientist
guy whose name I always know until now
he's the Hugo Channel man he's just he's
calculating as always watching over
everything from the controls do you want
to convince Greg to let us more of these
Hugo strangers you like you subscribe
you share you harass Greg on Twitter
nicely
benevolent arrests benevolent harassment
just reminders constant reminders this
is a blast love doing these with you
absolutely so much fun I love doing
these with you I look forward to them
every week yeah same soon next time same
day same bam same bat Channel and reject
me and last but not least we do a patron
of the day shut up
Chase The Gardener Chase listen man I
was thinking during this reaction I was
like man if we all got infected with the
Ooze Joker serum you know like what
animal would we each become so yeah you
know thinking I mean Chase Gardner you
have a very Elemental name you know the
the name Chase conjures up images of
emotion yeah so I'm thinking like maybe
you could be some kind of cheetah I was
thinking cheetah yeah like cheetah a
fast-moving cat but also I mean your
last name Gardener maybe you could be
something more Elemental maybe you would
be like a plant-based thing like poison
ivy or an animal that that helps the
planet like bees ooh you know like
pollinating like things that help like
you know plant they Garden in their own
way dude right I love that that's speedy
and gardening perfect Gardener you could
be the what's his name in B-movie Barry
b b man you could be Jerry Seinfeld you
could be very excited yes that would be
the oldest joke it's an animal you just
become Jerry Seinfeld in Bee Movie like
it becomes Jerry Seinfeld yes but like
it's it's either Jerry Seinfeld in the
sound booth or it's your side belt
version like he's just forever in a
sound booth and he only can do B movie
quotes he's actually a curse we're sorry
I'm so sorry I went from being great to
awful but that's the thing is by the end
of the shout out that we'll get you know
the the anti the the you know oh yeah we
got to fix whatever the anti-ohs
whatever she called she's smarter than
us
micro and I'm mutagen yeah either way
we're gonna change you back and we're
gonna come back to the drawing board and
find a way to make you that cheetah what
animal do you think you are uh lemur
maybe oh I like that for you like big
eye like yeah but like you know I like
that kind of neat still what about you I
also I too feel like a monkey
maybe an orangutan ooh I feel
orangutan-ish they seem like a lot of
energy but also like
friendly if you get to know them sure
but like if you don't it's like a lot
yeah they seem you know like kind of
kind of good nature yeah generally good
nature but if you mess around they'll
get you on Twitter
it's appreciate that she didn't add the
extra g at the end oh yeah it's not a
real primate no I mean I I respect the
the noble orangutan because uh Tang is
for space space chips oh look at that
also because yeah
I wonder if orangutan's ever gone to
space drink some orangutan oh that's a
marketing right there that's for free
Tang chasing space
[Music]
bars bars so comment if you get this far
let us know which animal each of us is
and if you uh want to get some tang with
an orangutan in space with Chase
[Laughter]
[Music]